c'est une nouvelle étape pour la colline
d'elancourt la solide et aux maîtres
d'ouvragé du projet a choisi cinq
entreprises pour aménager le futur site
qui accueillera les épreuves de vtt des
jeux olympiques de paris 2024 nous avons
beaucoup avancé entre autres avec
l'architecte spécialisés pour la
création des pistes d'un point de vue
sportif c'est à dire que le tracé des
pistes est arrêté je dis bien des pistes
à dire de la piste de paris 2024
elle-même mais également des pistes
secondaires annexes qui seront ouverts
au grand public une fois que les jeux
olympiques seront passées et puis nous
travaillons aujourd'hui je dis bien que
nous travaillons toujours avec la soli
deo sur les projets d'aménagement 10
millions d'euros d'investissements sont
prévus pour le projet sans constructions
en dur sur le site et avec une portée
écologique pour que de futures familles
sportifs amateurs et promeneurs puissent
s'y balader nous pensons pour les
aménagements pour ce que l'on appelle
l'héritage c'est à dire rendre encore
plus vert et pérenne l'ensemble de tout
ce que vous voyez plantés sur ce site
avec un point culminant à 2 131 mètres
d'altitude
les élus locaux espèrent voir en ce
nouveau lieu un vrai emblème de réussite
de ces jo 2000 24,1 il sera ouvert et
accessible
sachant qu'aujourd'hui certes la colline
est ouverte mais elle est difficilement
accessible
il ya des chemins qui sont même je
dirais de dangereux par moment puisque
il s'est quand même assez pentue c'est
compliqué d'y monter et de l'esthétique
n'aura rien à voir avec ce que c'est
aujourd'hui ça demeurera bien entendu le
point le plus haut d'île de france je
vous rappelle que du sommet de la
colline on voit la tour eiffel et envoie
tout paris mais ça sera également
certainement le point le plus
écologiquement respecté qui aura un vrai
bénéfice à la venue des jeux olympiques
de paris 2024 pas de date précise pour
les premiers coups de pioche mais en
attendant le département travaille déjà
sur les dispositifs de caméras pour une
meilleure retransmission possible